elle c'est jenny elle me suit partout
enfin non c'est plutôt moi qui la suit
dans la rue elle et mes yeux me fait
éviter les obstacles
mais si je lui demande elle sait aussi
trouver un passage clouté un escalier
voir un escalator un arrêt de bus une
station de métro
mais moi ce qui me bluffe le plus c'est
que dans son éducation de chiens guides
elle a même appris à désobéir mais que
si ça peut être dangereux
c'est dire s'il l'ordre que je lui donne
peut être dangereux pour nous dans ce
cas là elle se couche façon dire non là
on n'y va pas ok vous l'avez compris je
suis mal voyantes
ok malvoyantes ouais c'est bien beau
mais ça veut dire quoi
je vois quoi comme en rien un truc qui
est un peu pénible avec les malvoyants
c'est qu'on n'aime pas de avoir pareil
et comment puis je ne sais pas ce que
vous vous voyez
pour vous expliquer ce que moi je vois
c'est pas gagné bon allez on va quand
même essayer par exemple tiens allez
vous connaissez tous la couleur de vos
yeux
enfin je suppose ben moi je la connais
mais en théorie parce que même si
j'approche un miroir tout contre mon
visage je ne vois pas assez pour voir la
couleur de mes yeux autre chose tient au
boulot quand il ya nouveaux collègues
qui arrive dans le service je le mets à
l'aise tout de suite fut du coût de ces
simples s'il matin t'as pas envie de me
dire bonjour je te donne la recette
tu passes à côté dans le couloir tu
ferme la bouche tu dis rien et je saurai
jamais que tu es passé là ça peut être
pratique bon l'inversé pas or m
quoi dire d'autre
bah oui du coup quand on y voit aussi
peu faut bien trouver des stratagèmes
pour y voir
moi j'ai choisi d'y voir avec mon
cerveau et je vous rassure j'ai pas
fumer la moquette rouge avant de venir
l'impact n'en voir avec son cerveau ça
veut dire quoi mais ça veut dire que en
fait vous le faites tous mais vous le
savez pas vous vous le faites un petit
peu moi je le fais beaucoup ça veut dire
que par exemple un tiens si je vois
quelqu'un je devine que dans sa main il
ya une forme fine blanche
on peut allonger en gros je me dis tiens
qu'est ce que ça peut être alors des
deux possibilités par expérience soit
c'est un gamin qui vient de finir une
sucette
ok mais si c'est un adulte je vais
plutôt opté pour l'option cigarettes qui
l'a pas encore allumé
voilà c'est ça avoir avec son cerveau
enfin pour moi donc ça je fais ça en
permanence tout le temps tout le temps
oui parce qu'en fait je suis né
malvoyantes bon avec en plus une
malformation cardiaque mais bon on n'est
plus à ça près ok je suis né comme ça
mais malgré tout des trois quatre ans
j'avais des rêves plein la tête
des rêves de gosse mais pas uniquement
plus gros désir ce que je voulais par
dessus tout c'était vivre une vie
normale comme celle de tous les enfants
de mon âge
pour commencer les dû aller à l'école
normal non logiquement je réduis
entraînant une classe avec d'autres
enfants déficients visuels au sein d'un
établissement spécialisé
quand ils m'ont vu débarquer mais en
fait ils ont dit à mes parents
écoutaient elle a l'air de capter assez
vite
elle al'air ville dynamique on va vous
proposer de tenter une expérience c'est
à dire qu'en fait pourquoi ne pas
l'inscrire dans l'école de votre
quartier
nous sommes alors en 1975
et depuis quelques mois une offre une
loi offre cette possibilité
autant vous dire que à ce moment là nous
n'étions vraiment vraiment pas nombreux
en france à tenter l'expérience
ouais je dis expérience parce que
c'était même un sacré challenge
imaginez vous arrivez à suivre en classe
sans jamais voir ce qui était écrit au
tableau
d'ailleurs dès fois je voyais même pas
où il était le tableau est juste en
écoutant ce que disait la maîtresse
heureusement j'ai été bien aidé mes
parents notamment ce que faisait la
maîtresse c'est que pour que je puisse
lire ce qu'elle allait donner à lire en
classe la maîtresse donner quelques
jours auparavant à ma maman où mon père
faire mes parents les textes qu'elle
allait utiliser et e recopier tous en
très grosses lettres alors normalement
derrière apparaît effectivement alors ma
mère est pas au courant désole sa jolie
écriture où effectivement elle recopier
tous en très très grosses lettres pour
que j'arrive à lire l'établissement
spécialisé qui m'avait quand même pas
lâcher dans la nature comme ça et qui
effectue un suivi et donner des conseils
à la fois aux instituteurs et ouvre à
mes parents me fournisse édes ego cahier
avec des très très grosse ligne jaune
des cahiers que je puisse taille des
lignes que je puisse arriver à voir pour
que je puisse écrire dessus et apprendre
à écrire et qu'elle est en couverture
marron
moi je les aimais pas trop mais bon
voilà mais bref avec tout cet attirail
autant vous dire que mon rêve de
normalité
on avait pris un sacré coup si seulement
si seulement je pouvais utiliser les
cahiers normaux ça laisse avec les
toutes petites lignes là qu'il est jolie
couverture colorée mal an moi j'avais
même lâché un marron moche à cela avec
des grosses lignes jaunes et qu'une
envie
c'était un jour arriver à utiliser c'est
beau cahier et à force de force et
durant l'année de ce2 j'ai réussi
enfin mon premier rêve s'est accompli
c'était magique
les années passent et je continue ma
scolarité
bon c'était pas ça enfin parce que
pendant que les copains pouvait se
contenter de allez on va dire de
recopier ce que la maîtresse écrivait au
tableau et puis papauté temps en temps
moi il fallait que je sois concentré de
la première à la dernière minute du
court pour tout écouter tout noté pas
question de divaguer et de dire était en
fait dit quoi non ça c'est pas possible
donc je m'accroche et puis bah j'ai bien
fait parce que j'ai fait des études
quand même enfin que moi j'ai trouvé
très intéressante puisque après le bac
sur suggestion de mes profs de terminale
je me suis retrouvé en prépa lettres
bon je savais pas trop quoi faire donc
ça tombe bien c'est intéressant c'était
chouette
après je suis allé à sciences po licence
puis maîtrise en droit et un ds est en
gestion d'entreprise mais j'ai oublié de
vous dire un truc savez l'année là où
j'ai réussi à utiliser les cahiers la
seule couverture colorée
j'avais 8 ans et ça faisait trois ans
que j'avais ma troisième étoile en ski
enfin non pas trois ans j'exagère trois
mois bon c'est pareil mais j'avais ma
troisième étoile en ski à 8 en quoi
c'était cool c'était comme tout le monde
ça enfin peut-être pas mais pour moi oui
tout ça parce qu'en fait depuis l'âge de
4 ans je suivais mes parents sur les
pistes de ski
ça c'est un bien grand mot homme parce
que je suivais surtout leur silhouette
qui était juste devant mes skis allez
suivez moi fermez les yeux
je vais vous expliquer comment on skie
quand on n'y voit pas grand chose
fermez toutes les yeux la piste
défilent sous vos skis un des verts à
gauche par on appuie sur le ski gauche
pour pas déraper virage à gauche droite
gauche une bosse la belle affaire mais
je fille et mes genoux amortissent comme
qui rigole gauche droite gauche
l'écart de mai ce qui s'ancre dans la
neige j'accélère gauche droite gauche
droite comme ça au fil des virages d'une
saison d'un univers à l'autre
je suis devenu une plutôt bonne skieuse
et à l'âge de 21 ans j'ai intégré
l'équipe de france de ski alpin
handisport
après avoir écumé les pistes pyrénéenne
j'ai découvert les pentes enneigées
autrichiennes italiennes suisses
allemandes espagnoles et même japonaises
et américaines
au gré des coupes du monde championnats
du monde ou jeux paralympiques
mais là vous allez vous dire mal est
complètement barge pour ce qu'il y à 100
kilomètres heures sans voir plus loin
que le bout de ses skis peut-être
j'étais pas seul on était au moins deux
parce que quand je skie et un autre
skieur devant moi qui me donne toutes
les indications à la voix alors
qu'est-ce qui me dit ben il va me donner
la direction
gauche ou droite il va me donner les
obstacles
si on arrive sur une bosse une cassure
une compression en compétition une bonne
les figures du tracé aussi et pour le
diamètre des courbes ou le rayon comme
vous voulez on peut chipoter
il fait ça à l'international c'est à
dire par exemple en course de descente 1
gauche
donc c'est des grandes courbes large à
gauche ça va faire gojko gauche
par contre en slalom spécial savez les
picots et les piques et là qui sont tous
entassés les uns derrière les autres
c'est un combat de boxe mais la safer
droite gauche droite voilà donc autant
vous dire que pour en arriver là c'est
des années entre d'entraînement ensemble
c'est une super confiance mutuelle c'est
de la synchronisation et ça se travaille
à la fois sur les skis et en dehors des
skis dans la vie de tous les jours en
douze ans de carrière j'ai eu deux
guides
le premier qui est d'ailleurs sur la
photo que vous voyez qui m'a guidée de
1994 à 2002 qui avait déjà guidé donc
avec qui quelque part j'ai un peu appris
le guidage est mon métier entre
guillemets puisque c'était pas un métier
mais j'ai appris on va dire mon métier
de compétiteurs sous été arrêté en 2002
parce que il estimé ne plus avoir un
niveau suffisant pour me guider
donc ça devenait un peu dangereux donc
du coup j'ai trouvé un autre guide
enfin une autre guide qui était une
ancienne compétitrice
alors elle était au top niveau ce qui
par contre le guidage les connaissez
rien donc on a appris sur le tas j'ai dû
lui apprendre à se débrouiller pas mal
mais les premières semaines je trouvais
qu'il manquait un truc et fallait bien
trouver une solution pour qu'elles
captent vraiment ce dont j'avais besoin
donc un jour j'ai eu des coups tu tiens
on va sur cette piste là je les connais
bien et on va inverser les rôles les
minimes et est arrêté
bah ouais mais on est deux parce que tu
vas le faire
donc elle a mis un bandeau savait que
d'habitude nous met sur la tête là je
suis dit allez tu baisses mais sur les
yeux donc elles baissent le bandeau et
ne me dit pascal t ou jeudi a tu vois il
faut parler ok allez je te signale que
t'as pas encore bougé alors panique pas
on va y aller
bon là peu raide ans il a fallu trois
virages pour tout comprendre
on n'allait pas vite importants mais
voilà donc au bout de trois virages et
s'arrête et me fait si bon c'est bon
j'ai compris et c'est vrai elle a tout
compris
à partir de là on a trusté les podiums
internationaux assez souvent sur la
première marche il faut dire
bon j'étais un peu la bête à abattre par
les autres équipes mais c'est pas grave
on s'en fiche mais il savait gagner une
centaine de titres à peu près sur la
scène internationale en ski alpin quand
on n'y voit pas grand chose c'est
presque plus facile que j'ai de gérer
toutes les galères de la vie quotidienne
lesquels par exemple trouver une adresse
quand on peut pas lire un plan ou quand
on ne peut pas voir les numéros de rue
ou unis même les non retirer de l'argent
à un distributeur automatique de billets
alors je sais pas ce que font les
banques qu'elles doivent faire un
concours à celui qui aura l'écran le
plus original ya la pâte 2 qui se
ressemblent un possible de mémoriser le
truc du style voulez vous un reçu alors
un coup c'est will et à gauche un coup
oui il est à droite
impossible d'apprendre les boutons
parker et de se dire d'abord en il a
ensuite j'appuie la non il faut
quelqu'un qui voit autre exemple tiens
pour faire ses courses
oui parce qu'il faut bien manger balaj
istres développer ma propre stratégie
quand j'arrive dans un hypermarché un
grand magasin voire même une supérette à
ça marche aussi
j'apprends enfin à force je vais un peu
toujours au même endroit je triche mais
c'est bien pratique
j'apprends l'emplacement des rayons et
surtout ce qu'on trouve à quel endroit
ap le rayon des légumes il est en
entrant à gauche ou au rayon du céréales
riz tout ça c'est le deuxième à droite
mais une fois qu'on a fait ça on n'a pas
tout résolu
donc après j'apprends dans l'emplacement
des céréales le riz et au début à droite
elle épate elles sont un peu plus loin à
gauche
bon très bien et quand on se trouve
devant le rayon de pâtes
rappelez vous la dernière fois que vous
avez fait les courses
combien il ya de paquets de pâtes
différents
or soit gens pris au hasard qui je leur
ai bien une fois dans mon assiette ce
que c'est soir ma technique afin que je
préfère personnellement c'est que je me
dis bah tiens le paquet qu'on achète
d'habitude il est bleu j'ai pas dit il
marque donc le paquet il est bleu donc
je vais chercher quelque chose de bleu
donc je prends un truc bleus je regarde
c'est pas ça je propose
je prends celui d'à côté enfin bon un
peu plus loin parce que bon voilà donc
ça prend un peu de temps et ça marche ça
marche
jusqu'à ce que pour des raisons purement
marketing
le chef du magasin et la super bonne
idée de tout chambouler de rendre mettre
le riz à la place de la lessive et moi
j'arrive je cherche mon riz et là je
trouve super homo un super bon bon ça ça
me fait ça me fait râler mais bon j'ai à
dire c'est comme ça mais il ya un truc
qui m'énerve qui m'énerve vraiment c'est
l'injustice
l'injustice est encore pire quand elle
devient banal voire même normal par
exemple la loi française stipule que
lorsqu'on se déplace avec un chien guide
le chien guide ne doit pas payer les
transports trains taxis etc
et bien c'est très très souvent que les
chauffeurs de taxi essaye de facturer
l'euro symbolique mais leur os pour le
chien guide
comme chez un peu têtu à chaque fois je
leur rappelle que bah non c'est la loi
et alors ils font semblant de pas savoir
alors que c'est dans leur formation ils
sont tous au courant mais c'est pas
grave
donc la justice avec une bonne dose de
mauvaise foi par dessus ça m'énerve mais
bon qu'est ce que vous voulez sa force
de répéter qu'on y arrivera mais il n'ya
pas que les taxis un ver challenger
direct c'est les chambres d'hôtes ah ça
c'est assez fort alors de vue j'ai
annoncé voilà jeu quand je passais une
réservation bonjour voila je voudrais
une chambre machin je suis accompagné
d'un chien guide annoncé complet bon
monsieur rendu compte que quand je
disais plus que j'avais le chien guide
d'accueil avait il y avait des places
donc ce que j'ai fait pour mes dernières
vacances
donc c'est bon j'avais une chambre n'est
qu'elle échange par mail top
vous arrivez à quelle heure tu reviens
18h30 au fait j'oubliais de vous dire je
suis accompagné d'un chien guide
cinq minutes après j'avais un mail
ceux-ci annuler votre réservation
bah voilà et qu'ils voulaient que je
fasse
bah rien on est allé à l'hôtel bon
tout ça pour dire que je suis loin
d'être super woman pas du tout mais
quand on est handicapé aujourd'hui et
qu'on veut prendre sa place dans la
société
la place qui est promise à n'importe
quel citoyen eh bien il faut se battre
se battre pour tous pour la moindre
chose pour la moindre banalité faut se
surpasser en permanence moi je voulais
juste vivre une vie normale
on peut dire je me suis bien plantés en
fer en tout cas jusque là j'ai vécu des
choses compliquées complexe pénible
parfois mais j'ai aussi vécu des choses
très belles et très forte en tout cas
une chose dont je suis sûr c'est que
j'ai vécu des choses extraordinaires
admis lundi nout